good paying manufacturing construction
jobs across the country and strengthen
our economy for three decades america
has lost semiconductor manufacturing to
countries like china but since president
bayern took office that tide has turned
he's prioritized investing in critical
supply chain chains like chips and set
out a clear path to do so with his
executive order and he brought together
labor and business to get it done in
doing so we've catalyzed the industry's
outlook and gave them confidence in
america again including intel's
announcement today of a 20 billion
dollar investment in ohio and a total of
over 80 billion dollars invested since
he took office this is the power uh the
president is using to make it uh in
america to make uh to
support his made in america vision he's
putting into action those sorts of
investments have never been more
important particularly as we see a
global shortage of chips driving up
prices of cars right here in america
as we know it counts for about one third
of the inflationary pressure with auto
prices contributing
as a big part of that today's
announcement is just the latest progress
in our efforts to ramp up domestic
manufacturing tackle near-term
bottlenecks especially with critical
goods like semiconductors earlier this
year samsung texas instruments and
micron announced 80 billion dollars in
investments in semiconductor
manufacturing congress can accelerate
this progress by passing the u.s
investment and competition act also
known as uca which the president has
long championed in which he called for
action on today this bipartisan
legislation puts historic funding behind
unclogging our supply chains research
and development innovation and advanced
manufacturing in every corner of america
and invest 52 billion dollars in making
more chips something that's vital to
address our supply chains and lower
inflation tomorrow also marks the 49th
anniversary of the supreme court's
landmark ruling in roe v wade
reproductive health care has been under
extreme and relentless assault ever
since especially in recent months it has
been nearly 150 days since women in
texas have been denied these
constitutional rights we're deeply
committed to making sure everyone has
access to care and we will defend it
with every tool we have that includes
continuing to work with congress to pass
the women's health protection act and
codify this fundamental right into law
in the meantime the administration has
taken a range of important actions from
repealing the global gag rule to
strengthening title 10 family planning
program today hhs announced additional
title 10 grants and there will be
further announcements coming from hhs
later as well this is a moment for us to
recommit to strengthening access to
critical reproductive health care defend
defending the constitutional right
established by roe and protecting the
freedom of all people to build their own
future i know we have a short time
window today we will keep
up to date on when everybody needs to
gather and i'll try to get to as many
people as possible and otherwise i'll be
here in my office go ahead thank you all
right jen uh when uh
the us presents its written response to
russia next week is it willing to offer
russia something that goes beyond
uh
repeatedly stated positions particularly
when it comes to russia's demands on
guarantees regarding nato's future
expansion
we will put in writing as you reference
the serious concerns that we and other
allies and partners have about russia's
actions as well as ideas for how we
might actually strengthen each other's
sense of security going forward there
are several steps we can take that are
being discussed all of us russia
included to increase transparency to
reduce risk to advance arms control to
build trust we're coordinating uh with
our allies and partners and we
anticipate uh that secretary blinken and
foreign minister lavrov will meet again
to continue discussions and the
president obviously is regularly briefed
every day by his team but also be
engaging with them tomorrow over the
course of the weekend as well but as
secretary blinken
said today he made clear to foreign
minister lavra that there are certain
issues and fundamental principles that
the united states and our partners and
allies are committed to defend and that
includes those that would impede the
sovereign right of the ukrainian people
to write their own future there's no
trade space there none and we've said
from the beginning that there are
certain proposals that will not be
viable but we will of course be uh
responding as you noted and i expect the
president will continue to discuss that
over the next couple of days with his
team i wanted to ask another foreign
policy question um the strike in yemen
uh today um
70 people were dead uh are dead after
the saudi-led coalition strike
um national security advisor sullivan
immediately condemned um the recent
footy strike
um what's the administration's immediate
reaction to this strike and does this
company any reconsideration of
weapons sales to saudi arabia
i don't have any prediction of that at
this point in time obviously we have
uh have a long history of a relationship
with saudi arabia one where we raise
issues where we have significant
concerns on human rights
and on a range of issues and one where
we have had a long security relationship
that has been in the interest of the
united states
in terms of this specific strike and a
reaction
obviously any time there's a loss of
life of innocent lives that is a tragedy
and we uh we are mindful of that and
focused on that obviously you know our
focus and the president's focus which is
from the very beginning he established
new interim guidance concerning the
united states use of military force and
related to national security operations
that's how we operate here as the united
states which i think is reflective of
his of his view but certainly the loss
of life is is always a tragedy um and uh
again if there's anything new on uh on
our relationship i'm happy to uh get
that from our national security team at
just one last uh domestic uh with on tax
season uh with reduced uh staffing
levels less funding authorization from
congress irs already tasked with
distributing funds for several
pandemic relief programs
many 2020 refunds haven't been processed
how is the administration preparing to
ensure that this year's tax returns will
be processed
in a reasonable amount of time well i
would first note that a lot of this
predates this administration and you
touched on that but i think that's
important for people to understand
as the treasury department and the irs
have said the irs right now has an
unacceptable backlog and that customer
service and customer service that people
are receiving is not what the american
public deserves and the president is
very mindful of that many of those
challenges are related uh to the
pandemic and but also due to years of
underfunding from congress the agency
has not been equipped with the resources
it needs to adequately serve taxpayers
in normal times let alone during a
pandemic the president has prioritized
ensuring the irs gets 80 billion dollars
of stable multi-year funding resources
it can it needs to best serve the
american people as he said in his
executive order in december on customer
experience the american people deserve
an effective
equitable and accountable government
that meets the needs of its people so we
would call on congress to act now to
give the irs the funding it needs to
meet its goal uh but again in terms of
addressing the backlog it's going to
take some work it's going to take some
time and i think people need to
understand that they need funding but
they need to uh but there's a long
history here that's led to this moment
but thank you jen secretary blinken is
leading leaving geneva and so far does
not appear that he has a firm commitment
from russia not to
invade ukraine so is another summit
necessary at the legal level do you
anticipate that president biden
will be having a summit with president
putin the president
well let me first say that um you know
secretary blinken as you as you
mentioned in geneva today with the form
with foreign minister lavrov to share
our serious concerns with the situation
he warned russia that we are prepared to
respond to any russian invasion of
ukraine with swift and severe
consequences along with our allies and
partners we're also ready to continue
dialogue and diplomacy ultimately this
has always been putting the choices up
in front of president putin and the
russians right it is up to them to
decide which path they are going to
choose
secretary blinken also conveyed we don't
expect we didn't expect any
breakthroughs to happen today but we are
on a clear path in terms of
understanding each other's concerns uh
the president will meet this weekend to
camp david with his national security
team to discuss the
situation some will be virtual some will
be uh there in person we'll also
continue uh to consult with our allies
and partners and we will respond next
week in writing as i conveyed in terms
of the president
and his role um you know i think part of
that will be discussing with secretary
blinken and his national security team
what the appropriate next steps are of
course the president always values
leader to leader engagement but we'll
determine if that's the appropriate next
step no he's open to that he's always
been open
that's on the table it may or may not be
the next step but and i can't give you a
prediction of if and when it will happen
but uh if if that is the step that is
recommended and that we think would be
effective at this point in the
discussion of course the president's
always open to leader to leader
engagement let me ask you about
something that secretary blinken said he
told ukrainian tv that whether it's one
russian soldier or a thousand
crossing the border it's an attacking
ukraine does the president agree with
that statement is that how he said
that's the president president's policy
that he has directed as secretary of
state to continue to convey and what the
president conveyed to president putin
let me ask you about the electoral
account
based on some of my conversations on
capitol hill and obviously there seems
to be a growing consensus that there
might be able to be some progress on the
electoral account act someone said to me
that it could potentially be a vehicle
to get pre-clearance passed is that
something that this white house thinks
is a possibility is a likelihood is that
what the president's going to be pushing
for i don't have any prediction of a
process uh or a vehicle uh what i would
remind everyone of is that despite the
fact that 16 republicans in the senate
have in the past supported the
protection of voting rights they did not
when given the opportunity uh so again i
would note that the the electoral
account act is is something we we are
certainly open to but it is not a
replacement for and there are many
components of the voting rights
legislation that are vital to protecting
people's rights in this country you know
including the fact that we know that
voter suppression largely impacts
communities of color across the country
and one of the components of the voting
rights legislation the president's in
fighting for is requiring states that
have a history of voter suppression to
get approval to change their laws uh it
also uh these of these voting rights
legislation that we've been fighting so
hard for would also ensure that there's
a fundamental baseline of what people
can know and expect if you're a mother
of three you should be able to have many
places you can drop off your ballot or
vote this is not a replacement for that
in terms of a vehicle or what's possible
i don't have anything on that to read
out for you very quickly it seems like
they're going to be some discussions um
during break between lawmakers
bipartisan lawmakers about the electoral
count act and where they can find
consensus on this what can we expect the
president's role to be given that he's
been very clear
he is going to be taking a new strategy
as it relates to reaching out to the
american public
well the president can walk and chew gum
at the same time i think what people can
expect is that he's going to spend more
of his time
engaging with talking with the american
people and talking about how far we've
come and where we need to go from here
he also has a very talented and
experienced team that's already engaged
in a range of conversations with
congress uh but i can tell you from
spending a lot of time uh with the
president and in the oval office with
him that sometimes he just picks up the
phone and calls a member of congress or
senator when you're sitting there so no
one's suggesting that he's not going to
engage with members what we're conveying
what he heard from him the other night
is that
as you look at the time he's going to
spend over the next couple of months
it's not going to be hours and hours
behind closed doors in the oval office
good thank you jen
um why would the u.s agree to submit
written answers to russia given that it
could undermine or be used to discredit
the u.s negotiating position and is the
u.s asking for any written responses
from russia well no one sees it that way
from the us negotiating team or from our
partners and allies around the world i
think what we're engaged in here is
seeing what's possible as it relates to
diplomacy and as i noted it's not just
it's not written answers like we're
filling out a q a we're also going to
convey what our concerns are and
reiterate a number of the strong
statements you've heard the president
and secretary of lincoln convey very
publicly so this is just a part of the
diplomatic process in diplomatic
negotiations and has been a standard
part of the process often uh with
countries and nations where you have
agreements but also disagreements does
the president have a plan to evacuate
americans from uk
i know there have been um
a range of reports uh out this morning
which is probably why you're asking
jackie i will say that one we are
already at a level four travel advisory
for ukraine for covid and have advised
that u.s citizens have been advising
that u.s citizens should be aware of
reports that russia's planning for
significant military action against
ukraine we do conduct rigorous
contingency planning as we always do in
the event of the security any security
situation deteriorates in any country
around the world the state department
does that assessment i would point you
to them for any uh any predictions or
previews of any steps they may take is
there any effort right now to get a
handle on how many americans are in
ukraine's i remember with afghanistan
that was sort of an open question
is the dynamic different this time it's
an open question around the world we
don't put a chip in americans when they
go to countries around the world and
track their movements um people can
register with the state department
that's something they do or they may
choose not to register or there might be
people in any country around the world
who are dual citizens who haven't lived
in or have never lived in the united
states um but the state department would
certainly have the number in terms of
americans who have registered with the
state department
is the president aware that he was
caught on a hot mic yesterday why does
he appear to be dismissing the idea of
proactive returns
uh well the president certainly does not
dismiss that idea
considering he has taken a lot of steps
including uh supporting uh and approving
the uh several sanctions that were put
out by the treasury department just a
couple of days ago i would note that the
united states has delivered more
security assistance to ukraine in the
last year than any point in history in
the last year alone we committed 650
million dollars in security assistance
to ukraine in total since 2014 we have
committed 2.7 billion these deliveries
are ongoing including today there's more
deliveries coming in addition to
traditional security assistance such as
the ukraine security assistance
initiative the president has authorized
the presidential drawdown authority to
expedite lethal aid and meet ukraine's
emergency defense needs we've also
utilized third party transfers
authorized by the state department
allowing u.s allies and partners to
provide u.s origin equipment from their
inventories for use by ukraine
specifically the state department has
given the go-ahead for three nato allies
to rush anti-armor missiles and other
us-made weapons to ukraine and finally
in identifying additional equipment held
in dod inventories that can be delivered
under the access defense articles
program among other mechanisms we
recently notified congress of our intent
to deliver m17 helicopters so i would
say the president is hardly waiting
actions are pretty clear on that front i
want to ask you about something that you
said yesterday sure you told me
in response to it it was a ukraine
question um it's important to remember
who the aggressor is here the aggressors
russia and putin they are building up
military troops they are pushing out
misinformation in ukraine so why does it
seem like u.s officials are so concerned
about being seen
as escalating things if russia has
created this whole crisis
because i think we want the american
public and also the global community to
be clear-eyed about propaganda and they
are pushing propaganda about ukrainians
uh certainly there's propaganda pushed
here in the united states but this is
about a foreign potential foreign
conflict uh it's about the buildup of
troops by one power
that is a much larger uh
military power than the other on the
border and we want to be very clear with
the public about the realities and the
facts one final question on a different
topic yeah
on crime yesterday the manhattan d.a
clarified his memo
about downgrading certain crimes and um
he said armed robberies for instance
will be prosecuted as felonies violence
against police officers won't be
tolerated clearing up some of the
confusion around
how that office intended to prosecute
crimes does the white house have a
reaction to that or welcome
that kind of clarification given that
these questions do keep resurfacing i
don't have any reaction from here to the
decisions of a local district
i think it's a prosecutor or district
attorney d.a um i would say that the
president and and he'll talk about this
he'll talk about crime and he asked me
about this yesterday but you i think can
expect to hear him talk a little bit
about uh crime during his uh during his
remarks later this afternoon uh the
president believes that no one in this
country should worry about whether it's
safe to ride the subway or go to or the
bus or go to work or walk home at night
and that's why he's put more cops on the
beats that has stepped up efforts to get
illegal guns off the streets and
invested in proven community
anti-violence programs also why he's
doubled federal support for community
policing with 300 million dollars more
for cities plus another 700 million more
to bolster federal law enforcement we've
been working with mayors and local
leaders on this but i think the
president's record his commitment uh
speaks for itself go ahead first just a
quick follow-up to what you said about
the u.s agreeing to put response in
writing are you saying that the world
should not view that as the united
states making a concession to russia
i think you should see what it has to
say but it's part of a negotiation we've
been very clear about what we are not
negotiating on which is the sovereignty
of ukraine which is this question that
is continuously raised about ukraine's
right to pursue uh joining nato that's
up to nato countries to make that
decision and you've heard the president
tony blanken and others say time after
time that we are not making any
decisions about ukraine without ukraine
no decisions about europe without europe
but negotiating takes many forms it
takes forms where you're in person it
takes forms where there's an exchange of
written materials that's pretty standard
and has been in diplomacy for decades i
know you've been ask something similar
but yesterday again uh
minority leader mcconnell said that the
u.s should send forces to shore up
nato's eastern flank not if and when
putin escalates but now before it's too
late
what is your response why why wait well
first of all we work
in close coordination with our nato
partners and allies
and and in respond to what their needs
are we've been very clear and the
president's been clear that we will
support whatever their needs are should
they have security needs but i don't
have anything more to predict for you at
this point in time if i may ask one
quick domestic question just yesterday
you were talking again about the idea of
chunking off parts of buildback better
yeah chunking a bad word
maybe not the right phrase what's the
better word um splitting off breaking
apart seeing if there was a certain uh
policy proposal that you maybe could get
60 votes on anything else you can tell
us about
which policy proposal you guys might
feel hopeful about is that universal
pre-k is it paid sick leave where do you
guys feel like you might actually be
able to get 10 republicans well you tell
me is there a proposal where there are
10 republicans i'm not aware of one
maybe there is um and there are some
senators who have been out there saying
they support different components i know
senator romney has said he supports or
is open to some component of the child
tax credit he's not the only one are
there 10 republicans they can get to
support that great let us know or have
to have a discussion about it that's not
what the president was talking about the
other night what the president was
talking about is getting as much
although we're very open to that but
what the president was talking about is
we have 50 votes in the senate you need
we're going to get as much a big
mountain sized chunk whatever you want
to call it as much as we can of the
build back better agenda
that we can get 50 votes for there is
clear agreement on some key goals right
lowering the cost of child care
negotiating the price of prescription
drugs uh
lowering the cost of elder care making
sure the wealthiest americans and
companies have to pay more in the
unfairness of the tax system so we have
to figure out is how much of that we can
get and get approval for
your focus is still on a reconciliation
partisan package absolutely
it's it's not that it's not it but you
tell me or you're i know you've covered
the hill before but are there are there
10 republicans who are supporting we'd
be happy to we don't we don't actually
it's kind of a mystery
listen if there are 10 republicans who
want to come support the child tax
credit or something else great they're
welcome let's have a conversation about
it but um you know that's not i don't
really know why none of us know why
they're seating the ground on supporting
the lord in the cost of child care to us
but so far they have go ahead thanks jen
um
over the weekend insurers started paying
for uh at home tests or you could apply
for reimbursement
uh but medicare is not i know that uh
medicare recipients can go through their
doctors and some through advantage
programs can get reimbursement but
broadly members of the program
can't and i'm wondering why not uh this
seems like a group that would be
that you would most want to sort of be
vigilantly testing before going to
gatherings it's their
filter and therefore muster risk for
covid and
especially since you said yesterday that
you had all the money that you needed to
fight covet right now
why isn't the government paying for
these tests well first there are a
couple things that are happening you
kind of glossed over some of them but
let me give you some specifics so state
medicaid and chip programs are required
to cover uh at home covet tests um cms
has also issued guidance to states to
effectuate this requirement under
medicaid rules there are a lot of people
who are eligible for medicaid out there
just to be clear and chips program
and people who are covered by original
fee for service medicare medicare pays
for coveted diagnostic tests performed
by laboratories such as pcr and antigen
tests for medicare we're also continuing
to explore the best ways to provide
critical resources that will keep
medicare beneficiaries safe and healthy
as as you touched on so in addition to
pcr tests
rapid pr tests pcr tests and rapid point
of care antigen tests um
are are available at 20 000 sites across
the country we've also sent 50 million
out to community health centers and
rural health centers but we're also
exploring a range of options so i'm not
ruling anything out but i just wanted to
note there are a range of ways that
different forms of insurance even if
it's not traditional private insurance
have been covering not just in
in doctor's office but also
at home tests as well
the federal reserve issued a report
yesterday saying that they're weighing
the possibility of launching a digital
u.s currency
they said as part of the report that
they were asking for public feedback and
would be engaging with with lawmakers so
i know that you normally defer to the
independence of the fed but this is a an
instance where they're
openly soliciting sort of advice and
consultation and so i'm wondering
you know this is something that could
impact our competition with china have
an impact in many ways on especially
low-income americans so does the
president does the white house have an
opinion on on this sort of question i
think it's unlikely we'll weigh in from
here as much as they've asked for public
comment but i can certainly check with
our economic team and see
the times yesterday had a report about
some internal memos but they also said
that there was uh that you guys are
setting up executive actions on uh
clemency for
drug offenders and and uh police
department reforms can you give any sort
of time can you confirm that that's kind
of coming and give any sort of timeline
about when we'll be hearing from the
president so on on
clemency the president uh has talked
about we we have talked a little bit
about the president wanting to deliver
on his commitment to
um consider uh clemency requests for
non-violent drug offenders that is
something that's ongoing i don't have
any anything to preview for you in terms
of the timeline but absolutely the fact
that
we have every intention of doing that is
accurate or he has every intention on
police reform you know i think we said
at the time that we had we're holding
back on executive action because uh we
wanted to give space and room for the
bipartisan negotiations to move forward
because of course federal legislation is
it would be the preference because it's
permanent uh but we have been
considering and looking at i don't have
anything to predict for you in terms of
the timing but we we have been in our
looking at that through the policy uh
teams
thanks jen the president on wednesday
when he was talking about keeping
schools open referenced the tens of
billions of dollars that were sent out
in the coveted rescue plan and he said
that not quote not every district views
has used it as well as it should be used
what states or school districts is he
referring to there because he's talked
about this now twice in the last couple
of weeks sure well thank you for that
first because it's freezing in here i
think because everyone can confirm um
but um i would say karen so one what
people should understand first is 98 of
schools are open currently uh it
fluctuates a little bit but 98 as of
today
school districts for the most part are
spending federal relief funding by and
large across the country
part of what the president's message he
wanted to hammer home when he spoke the
other night and as you said he's talked
about this a little bit is to spend the
money right now uh for for any school
that has some left or maybe some haven't
spent all of it and i'll get to that in
a moment and it's important for any of
these school districts to know that
different school districts spend it in
different ways so in dekalb county in
georgia and desert sands in california
they're investing in safety measures
like ventilation cup bank school
districts in montana are increasing pay
and providing bonuses to help retain
educators and staff there's lots of ways
to use it and spend it for those who
haven't done it um but we're continuing
to exert pressure anywhere that hasn't
so in terms of an example would be
florida where they have done little to
uh to distribute money uh to little to
no steps to distribute money to state
across the state and to school districts
um now part of it is you have to write a
plan for how you're going to keep
schools open to get the third tranche of
money and some have been delayed in that
but right now that's an example of a
state that could do more you just said
you know we're exerting pressure how is
the white house obviously this money
goes out to states yeah but how is the
white house exerting pressure the
department of education is really the
primary conduit here but um they have
been working and continuously in touch
with school districts and states
across the country from the beginning
from the department of education
perspective to have a public accounting
so americans can see where that money is
going towards the taxpayer money
we of course work to ensure there's no
waste fraud and abuse and we are very
closely in touch with how it's being
spent with states um and i can certainly
check and see if there's a public
accounting one quick one it's been four
days since kovates.gov has been live how
many americans have ordered tests so far
and is the plan still to start sending
them out next week yes uh they will be
sent out very soon um i don't have an
updated number of how many have been
ordered it's changing constantly i
expect we will have a more of an update
on that hopefully by next week i know we
have to wrap up go ahead
on buildback better
first does the white house uh need this
bill to be passed by state of the union
is that the goal you know congress kind
of needs deadlines
we have not set a deadline on that we
want to get it done as quickly as
possible
does it need to have a different name
speaker pelosi suggests it perhaps
we'll see do you have any ideas
actually
you guys are all worth it no wait no
i've got a few yeah um on the electoral
account act yes i know you said that the
president has many conversations on a
wide range of topics with lawmakers on
the hill um but here's the question it's
a bipartisan group right now is he going
to let them work on their own for the
moment or is he getting engaged with the
mansion college group now
our team is closely engaged with all the
members who are discussing every
component of any legislation that is
being discussed on the hill including
this
let me let me go to jeff because i just
i just don't want to run out of we gotta
wrap up so you guys can gather go ahead
jeff sorry
a federal judge in texas has ruled that
president biden's mandate for federal
workers to be vaccinated
cannot go through do you have a reaction
to that well first let me update you
that 98
of federal workers are vaccinated uh
that is a remarkable number uh i would
point to the department of justice on
any next steps as this news it sounds
like just broke but obviously we are
confident in our legal authority here we
had an event with intel today is the
white house concerned about intel's
presence in china
uh we have obviously uh spoken about uh
concerns we have had i'm not familiar
with all the specifics of their uh of
their engagement in china so i'd have to
check with our team we have not held
back i should say if we have concerns
about engagement in parts of the country
where there are human rights abuses we
also do at the same time work with a
range of companies uh even when we voice
our vocal our concerns about uh issues
that we don't agree with let me do this
last one linda another intel question
okay so they're planned for a 20 billion
dollar semiconductor facility in ohio
uh how can this be viewed as an
immediate solution to the chip shortage
if the plants
well i think our view is it's an
important step forward in ensuring that
we have manufacturing capacity here in
the united states that we don't have a
chip shortage in the future but we also
the president called for the passing of
euseka i just reiterated at the top of
the briefing so that we can get that 52
billion dollars in semi-conductor
investment to to get more going now
what's the hold up that you seeker in
the house
i think speaker pelosi made clear she
wants to move it forward so we're eager
the president's eager to have it signed
okay sorry i gotta wrap it up guys you
guys gotta gather i'll see you guys
i know uh i would what's the what's the
fruit i would do anything for love
hurting you
he might say that